bạn hôm nay hôm nay có vẻ on hơi
sẽ có cái l heer này
ok
có nghĩ tôi nghỉ thc ra
tôi tôi bị ngủ quên kiểu là báo thức rồi
nhưng có vẻ là
ờ dạng là cũng chắc là do Phòng hơi ồn
ngủ không để ý gì luôn ạ Đúng là thời
tiên ngoài Hà Nội bây giờ khá là dễ ngủ
đi ok
dở đến à mình làm mình tiếp tục làm đến
clear cách rồi các thứ rồi nhỉ
Ờ bây giờ thì tôi không biết được bây
giờ tôi sẽ ngồi tâm sự hay là tôi sẽ
ngồi ngồi làm tiếp Xong rồi đến cuối
buổi tâm sự nữa
Ờ hôm trước thì có bảo là
kiểu
Ờ tôi sẽ chia sẻ thêm cho mấy ông nhiều
cái đúng không
thôi hôm qua Thực ra tôi
ờ lại nghĩ lại về Cái này và thực ra tôi
cũng
kiểu muốn tâm sự chính xác là học hỏi ý
kiến mấy ông về cái này
Ờ Cái
mà cái bass đồ này
nâng cao rồi mới xem sao với anh đúng
rồi cái dự án này là dự án web bán hàng
thực thực tế nên là để chắc được kiến
thức nó Nó là kiểu dạng là dạy cho
Junior muốn chở thà Sino kiểu kiểu thế
vẫn mang thên hướng là kiểu code nó khá
phức tạp trong đấy tự nhiên là mình vẫn
sẽ hỗ trợ giải thích code nhưng mà
Ừ thứ nhất là bạn phải biết về larel đã
thứ hai là nói chung là kiểu quen dần
với code các thứ thứ đã chứ mình mình
không dạy cơ bản trong cái khóa này đây
cũng không biết là dùng từ khóa hay
không chỉ là mình có đánh dấu
playlist ở trên trang cá nhân ấy thì bạn
sẽ thấy nó là một lớn nhất
Kiểu cái này là kiểu dự án thực
phải kiểu nắm rõ kiến thức cơ bản rồi
đúng không
ạ Cái nâng cao kia thực ra gọi nâng cao
th ra nó bản chất là nó cũng chỉ là kiểu
chuyên sâu đà sâu hơn gần TH thực tế hơn
so với cái cơ bản
thôi
Ờ thì tôi định hỏi mấy ông về cái vụ này
Ờ thực ra có có ông ở đây thì biết đến
tôi rồi biết tôi ngoài đời rồi thì sẽ
thấy là tôi là kiểu là là một ông it
thích khá thích là mua sắm mua sắm C mua
mua mấy cái đồ lọt vặt linh tinh kiểu
phan cuồng Xiaomi chẳng hạn mua một đống
đồ Xiaomi các thứ
biết được Tôi hay mua đồ Xiaomi nhiều
nha nhá Nhưng mà sau những cái giây phút
hứng lên như thế thì có những lúc mình
thừa đồ nghĩa thực sự mình mua M biết
mình không cần đấy kểu thế Ờ hoặc là chỉ
Dạ là mua xong rồi cái cũ nó nó thừa nó
vẫn còn đang dùng
được thế là hơi khó thể nói về cái vụ
này Nhưng mà đại khái này kiểu bây giờ
tự nhiên t Mình thỉnh thoảng mình sẽ có
những cái đồ không dùng đến đúng không ạ
thâ Tôi không biết xử lý với cái đống đồ
này như nào không biết mấy ông có gợi ý
gì không
Ờ tôi thì tôi có nghĩ đến việc là hay là
tôi sẽ
kiểu pass đồ à đây cách kiểu kể các bạn
thường an nói là
kiểu
kiểu chẳng biết cái này kiểu tiếng Việt
bây giờ sẽ như th
à pass lại đồ pass đồ cũ sang tay chuyển
nhượng lại hàng hóa các thứ
tiếng nhỏ á
Alo tiếng nhỏ đợ Đợi tí
à Ok Cảm ơn đã nhá nhá bây giờ tiếng đủ
to hơn chưa ạ
kiểu bán lại đồ đâu vì tôi quan điểm
là kiểu Ừ thì nó vẫn còn đủ tốt thậm chí
là có cái mới mới tinh cơ để mua về
không dùng ấy nhưng mà tôi không Tôi cảm
thấy tiếc khi mà kiểu Tôi nghĩ là kiểu
tôi mua thì mục đích thể dùng chứ không
phải mua thì đơn giản bán lại hay các
thứ Nên là tôi định kiểu vẫn là giveaway
các thứ thứ nhưng mà về cơ bản thì gway
thì bây giờ gway ở đâu
đấy nên tôi đang tính đang tính C nh vụ
đấy tôi hoàn toàn thể ghi g miễn
Ờ trên discord cũng là một cách
có nhiều đố phết đấy Ờ chắc là tôi thậm
chí thậm chí là cả con bàn phím cơ của
tôi cũng được nó chỉ cũ thôi chứ nó vẫn
dùng rất là tốt Nó vẫn đang dùng ngon ha
Tôi đương nhiên là tôi sẽ phải họ như là
thứ các thứ xong xong rồi Kiểu pass lại
cho người nào cần kiểu thế
Ờ nói chong là tôi đang xin nghĩ khá
nhiều về vụ đấy bởi vì tôi khá nhiều đồ
là kiểu kiểu thế kiểu mình không cần thì
tôi nghĩ là người khác sẽ cần
Thôi mình sẽ cho người nào cần hơn các
thứ thứ cái này khá là khó để mà kiểu
bảo là cho từ thiện hay cái gì gì đó Bởi
vì bởi vì tính tính ra thì ví dụ kiểu tư
Thiện gì cho người khác cái bán phím cơ
đúng
không kiểu tôi là ví dụ một cái như thế
đúng không gì tôi thừa cái điện thoại
chẳng hạn đấy Tôi không muốn khái niệm
là bán lại chỉ là muốn kiểu cho ai có
như cầu cần
thì mình mình đang lên Xong rồi ai cần
thì mình gửi thế
cái gì thì pass lại nhưng quan trọng là
phải pass nó sau sao cho nó hợp lý phù
hợp không thì lại bị người ta nói đúng
không kiểu nói chung là cái này cũng cái
mình thấy là hơi tấy Nhị bởi vì có người
sẽ nhạy cảm n sẽ tự ái không biết
là sẽ kiểu thoải mái thôi Ví dụ mình tôi
nghĩa là ở đây có những bạn sinh viên
bạn ấy kiểu cũng có nhu cầu đúng không ạ
Đấy thì mình kiểu đại khái mình nh
Ừ mình sã đáp ứng được đúng nhu cầu bạn
review code đi anh Ờ có đấy chứ thực ra
là mấy ông hoàn toàn thể đăng ở trên
kênh
discord tạo mấy cái Hôm trước bảo mấy
ông ra bài tập làm website thp cưới mấy
ông còn chưa làm này nghĩa là mấy ông
hoàn toàn tạo thớt thớ ở đây xong rồi
mấy ông kiểu mấy ông đăng cái dự án mấy
ông lên à để mà à Kiểu tôi review qua
code hoặc là à Đăng CV lên để tôi review
qua CV cũng được đây có rất nhiều bạn
kiểu đăng lên tôi toàn tạo thớ xong rồi
Tôi hỗ trợ này nên là mấy ông hoàn toàn
thể đăng lên nhé Nói chung là tôi không
phải là mấy ông đăng cái là tôi sẽ trả
lời được ngay nhưng mà tôi luôn để ý cái
kênh đấy thên mấy ông đang hỏi đáp gì
hoặc là thậm chí inbox riêng tôi cũng sẽ
review hỗ trợ cho Nói chung là tôi thì
vẫn giúp hết sức trong khả năng mình
đúng không Không phải là không phải là
kiểu luôn luôn luôn luôn trực để hỗ trợ
nhưng mà nói chung là tôi cũng chẳng bỏ
qua tin nhắn của ai bâo
Ok tức ra cái vụ nhắc đến cái vụ này nó
nó nó lại liên quan một tí vụ dưới Tức
là sao tôi kiểu Tôi nghĩ về cái tôi là
một người tôi cảm thấy là tôi có khá
nhiều ý tưởng mà tôi khá muốn làm nhiều
thứ Ờ tính cách của tôi là con người
kiểu chắc là thích chia sẻ xong rồi kiểu
dạng là thích kiểu cho đi các thứ thứ
Thế ra đương nhiên là ai ai cho đi người
ta cũng mong nhận lại được cái gì đấy
tôi tôi không hẳn là mong nhận lại được
đúng cái thứ mình cho đi thì buồn cười
nói chung là tôi cảm thấy kiểu ví dụ là
kiểu cảm thấy là mình gọi nh mình có ích
có ý nghĩa thì tôi thích kiểu như thế
thôi thì tôi thích cho đi đấy
Ừ và ngoài thế tôi cái việc cho đi ở đây
tôi sẽ bao gồm việc à tôi hồi trước là
tôi thường ngay chia sẻ những cái phần
mềm những cái dự án Nói chung là làm
nhiều thứ kiểu cho xong rồi chia sẻ cho
cộng đồng để cộng đồng cùng dúng ví dụ
sắp tới này tôi lại chuẩn bị làm thêm
một vài cái dự án nữa kiểu dạng là chia
sẻ thì ai có ai có nhu cầu dùng thì dùng
giống như hồi trước tôi chia sẻ t ích
chặn quảng cáo kết hợp với anh cái sinh
chẳng hạn Ừ sắp tới thì sẽ định làm à
hồi trước đã từng có ý tưởng rồi không
biết hồi đ Tôi từng nói mấy ông chưa làm
cái trang web để chia sẻ nhạc chia sẻ
nhạc ở đây là không phải là mấy ông đăng
nhạc lên đấy mà Mấy ông sẽ lấy nhạc từ
những nguồn khác để mấy ông tầm hợp trên
trang đấy xong
rồi để chia sẻ cho người khác cho người
khác biết được cái gu gu nhạc của mình
chẳng
ạn cái đấy ch là tôi sẽ nói cụ thể xâu
hơn sau Nhưng đại khái tôi là tôi cảm
thấy tôi là người có rất rất nhiều ý
tưởng để làm rất nhiều thứ chẳng qua
mình thì mình không thể thần thánh kiểu
mình bao đầu s tay làm được tất cả mọi
thứ Nên là tôi hiện tại ra tôi cảm thấy
tôi may mắn khi mà tôi có đứa em kiểu
đúng kiểu đây trợn thủ đc lực cánh tay
trái Chắc là cánh tay phải hơn là cánh
tay trái nghĩa là tôi là một người có ý
tưởng còn cứ nhờ đứa em đấy để hỗ trợ để
làm
Ờ tôi nghĩ là
là có những lúc mình gọi như nà gọi là
đằng đằng sâu sự thành công của đôi khi
c c dự cái dự án của tôi không phải là
tôi mà À nhầm Ừ đúng rồi đằng sau sự
thành công Đấy đôi khi là sự đóng góp
thầm lạng của đứa em đấy Chẳng hạn
đấy mấy ông nghe cái đùa kiểu về Đặng
đằng sau thành công của một người đàn
ông là một người phụ nữ chú đáo cầu toàn
các thứ thứ chưa Thì ý tôi tôi có nghĩ
về cái hoản đấy Đó là kiểu không biết về
sau mà mình à Ờ kiểu quen bạn nào có thể
hỗ trợ được mình ví dụ Điền hình cái vụ
Pồ kia chẳng hạn có rất nhiều đồ Lạt vặt
hay các thứ thứ tôi muốn là kiểu thc ra
tôi muốn tôi có ý tưởng ấy Nhưng mà tôi
muốn có người hỗ trợ làm cùng tôi hoặc
là chỉ đơn giản là ngồi chỉnh sửa cái
đống video này chẳng hạn video nhiều mấy
cái video livestream kiểu như này tôi
cũng lười trình rửa vân vân mấy cái đấy
là mình có ý tưởng mình làm nhưng mà tôi
không muốn là kiểu mình mình làm hết ấy
Ờ có người nào hỗ trợ làm cùng ấy thì nó
sẽ đỡ
hơn
Ừ hồi trước thực ra là nhắc Thế hồi
trước tôi nhớ là tôi từng có chia sẻ m
một lần rồi và đã từng có vài bạn inbox
này hỗ trợ làm video trên tiktok mà và
hình như có đúng một cái video bây giờ
đang Hà trên
tiktok hồi đấy có bạn hỗ trợ nhưng về
sau bạn ấy cũng lại nghỉ vì bạn ấy cũng
bận các thứ tôi nghĩ là chắc là để khi
nào tôi sẽ comb lại sau sau chắc là phải
khá
sang nhiều nền tảng khác cặt chỉnh sửa
video các thứ nhưng mà Ờ về cái khái
niệm về cái trợn thủ đ lực này tô muốn
nói thì nó là
kiểu gọi là trợ thủ thôi Nhưng bản chất
như tôi vừa nói nó đôi khi là cái gì đó
rất là lớn kiểu làm một người anh anh
hùng thẩm lặng đằng sau để hỗ trợ cho
mình đôi khi là mình muốn làm một cái
giờ đó chúng ta không thể đi một mình
được chúng ta nên phải đi cùng cùng nhau
phải có một Tôi nghĩ là có rất nhiều lúc
là chúng ta sẽ cần một người đồng hành
cùng đấy
Ờ tôi thì tôi kiếm được một đứa em ấy
rồi nhưng mà đứa em đấy về cơ bản nó vẫn
còn trai có rất nhiều cái lặt vặt kiểu
mà tôi nghĩ là cần một bạn nữ hỗ trợ
chẳng hạn thế Thì đỡ hơn ví dụ vụ bass
đồ kia tôi Tôi nghĩ là con gái sẽ tinh
tế
hơn anh em mình thật bởi vì Tôi bảo nó
vẫn có thể một cái gì đó nhạy cảm bảo dạ
Tự nhiên đă bài kiểu Pồ xong rồi mình mà
nói không khéo là bạn ấy cảm tưởng như
là mình đang gì đó cho dù ý mình cái tâm
mình thì có thể tốt nhưng mà quan trọng
là cái cách cho đi nó khó tôi cảm thấy
thế Nghe khó đấy
làm được Chắc là tôi vẫn thể cho người
thân xung quanh như người thân xung
quanh tôi cũng gọi nhở tôi không quen ai
kiểu có nhu cầu cần lắm chẳng hạn hơi
khó có nghĩa là sẽ có nhiều bạn kiểu cần
thực sự cần
muốn cũng là ở trong cộng đồng là sinh
viên của tôi Chứ thực thực tế nhá Tôi
hoàn to đ Đăng miễn phí cái đấy Kiểu lên
bất kỳ nhóm nào trên Facebook mà hoàn
toàn các bạn thì kiểu Hưởng Hưởng nhanh
lắm kiểu tranh nhau nhưng mà mỗi tội là
tôi nghĩ là nó sẽ có bị nhược điểm nó
kiểu Khi mà mình đang miễn phí Thế là
rất nhiều bạn và sẽ lợi dụng kiểu Lấy
kiểu muốn lấy đồ bằng được thôi code đem
bán đi ý tôi không muốn thế có nghĩa là
sinh viên í nhất là sinh viên của mình
nó sẽ không như thế chắc
Thế mình nghĩ thế đúng không
tôi hiy vọng ông nào nghe được có cao
kiến gì thể hỗ trợ tôi về khoản
nhắc nhắc nĩ lại về vụ miễn phí Hồi
trước tôi cũng bảo rồi thì cái khóa học
tôi dạy cho mấy các bạn như này cũng
cũng cũng là kiểu miễn phí thôi thường à
thường là thường chuẩn là miễn phí nó sẽ
ít được lên lưu trân trọng nhưng mà thực
tế là có có những người họ thực Khi mà
gặp được đúng người thì họ cảm thấy là
ủi nó quý lắm nó không còn tí gì gọ
không trân trọng đâu rất nhiều người
kiểu ít nhất là kiểu trong cái mấy cái
khóa dậy của tôi này những bạn kiểu đặc
biệt là mấy bạn tránh ảnh ấy mấy bạn đây
kiểu rất là kiểu cảm thấy là kiểu được
dùng từ cứu nó hơi bị nặng nề quá nhưng
mà bạn đấy cảm thấy là bạn được có thêm
một cơ hội nữa mà cơ hội ở đây là bạn
không phải mất một cái đồng tiền nào để
biết đến kiểu như thế Bây giờ giả sử là
có đầy khóa học ở trên
thừ bạn đấy Kiểu bạn ấy đã tránh ngành
rồi Bạn ấy còn kiểu thấy là phải bỏ một
khoản phí để mà học cái này cái thử thử
bạn đấy Bị đắn đo lắm đúng không vây gi
tự nhiên có một cái miễn phí trên mạng
thì bạn nghĩ là tại sao không thử nhỉ
Cũng là miễn phí nhưng thực tế là cái
cái từ miễn phí này tôi bảo là nó thực
ra không hẳn miễn phí Bởi vì các bạn đấy
phải vẫn phải bỏ thời gian và công sức
ra để bạn ấy học đúng không nên là tôi
cảm thấy là những cái bạn ít nhất là
những cái bạn vào kênh tôi thì hiện tại
không phải chắc là không hẳn là vào hùa
các thứ theo số đông mà các bạn vẫn kiểu
Dạ cảm thấy Ừ vẫn có một cái giá trị gì
đó nhất định nên là tôi mới kiểu muốn
kiểu phát triển ở trong cái cộng đồng
nhỏ này có thử thậ chứ về sau mà giả sử
mà về sau nó về sao tôi nghĩ là tôi nếu
mà tôi đi dậy hoặc là làm trên giả vân
vân kênh Tôi nghĩ là và về sau sẽ đăng
thêm nhiều cái kiểu vân vân nữa thì cộng
đồng này sẽ lớn hơn thì lúc đấy thì cái
sự chọn lọc ha mọi thứ nó sẽ khó hơn Bây
giờ tôi nghĩ là nó vẫn còn đang gọi là
nằm trong tầm kiểm soát và vẫn còn giữ
được cái chất còn về sau thì đông hơn
thì đúng là khó kiểm soát hơn nhiều khó
nói
hơn Đúng rồi Mình dùng màn đôi chứ cái
để ngồi đọc bình luận này đúng không
thường một số code C cơ bản bao nhiêu
tiền anh
nhỉ Sợ dùng từ bao nhiêu tiền nếu mà giả
sử em khái niệm việc em bán ch người ta
thì là bây giờ một thằng để sinh ra được
cái đoạn code C kiểu dạng là pp thuần
hay kể cả là Framework thì thì thằng
thằng kiểu chity hay copilot vân vân vân
thích nó tự động sinh ra một đống là xịn
h nói rồi có tài bản rồi nên là và toàn
bộ mấy cái kiểu à repo Mấy cái kiểu mã
nguồn miễn phí ở trên github có đầy rồi
nên là tôi cảm thấy là nó không
nó không hề đáng giá Bởi vì khi mà khi
mà kiểu trên mạng có đầy rồi nhưng mà
bạn vẫn nên trân trọng nếu mà giả sử đó
sản phẩm của mình
còn việc mua thì tôi khuyên là không cần
mua trên mạng có đầy hoặc là dùng
Charity tự làm
cho một bên
à
Thì kiểu cái mức giá nó bao nhiêu hợp lý
để mà kiểu định giá ấy
thì thực ra là có khá nhiều khái niệm về
định giá đặc biệt là đồ cực nó liên quan
đến công nghệ chơ xám kiểu như này tôi
thường ha đánh giá nó hồi trước là nghe
đo bằng số giờ của ông V ví dụ nhá Giả
sử là ông Junio Ông cảm thấy
là ông một tháng ông đi làm được tầm À
cái cho 6 triệu giả sử 6 triệu nhá thì
tức là một ngày ông được 200 đúng không
nhở Ừ 200 một ng 200 200
thì 200 chia 8 nghĩa là 1 tiếng nghĩa là
1 giờ bạn sẽ kiếm được 25 tiếng
à 1 giờ bạn sẽ kiếm được 25.000 đấy thì
bây giờ bạn làm cái cái kia bao nhiêu
tiếng thì bạn nhân với 25000 lên để bạn
đánh giá được cái định giá đấy là mức cơ
bản nhưng mà đôi khi là bạn sẽ còn cộng
thêm với cái cái gọi là ví dụ Giả sử là
tuy là đoạn code đấy bạn thể code rất là
nhanh rất là đơn giản đối với bạn Nhưng
nó rất có giá trị với người bên kia th
kiểu là Ui người ta đem đoạn code kiểu
giả giả sử nhá Giả sử thôi ví dụ thôi
giả sử người ta đem đoạn s code Facebook
về xong người ta làm hẳn ra một cái
trang Facebook thứ hai đấy Xong rồi Kiểu
hàng triệu người user sử dụng được chẳng
hạn thế đ nh là ví dụ thế thôi nhá thì
rõ ràng đôi khi bạn dù kể cả bạn code
cái đấy có thể đơn giản như nào nữa bạn
vẫn Định giá có thể định giá lớn lên
bằng bằng chính cái lượng kiểu user tiếp
cận được như thế nghĩa là cái S code của
ông có thể chịu tải được lượng bao nhiêu
người dùng có thể đem lại cho họ bao
nhiêu doanh thu đấy thì bạn có thể cộng
với phần trăm của cái pht cái việc doanh
thu hay là lượng người dùng các thứ thứ
kia nữa dủ 10 ph đi đấy x đương nhiên
vẫn cộng với số giờ này ví dụ Giả sử thế
nghĩa là cái số code này có thể khiến
cho người ta kiếm được về 1 tỷ Mộ năm
chẳng hạn đấy thì bạn kiểu cộng thêm
phần trăm vào trong đấy các thứ thôi Cái
này là nhiều nên là cũng khó
thấy tâm đắc đi anh
Ừ tôi hồi trước tôi tự nhận tôi là mỏ
sách nhưng mà tính ra là rất lâu rồi tôi
không đọc sách đây mấy ông sẽ thấy là
tôi có cái tiện X này mấy ông thấy ở đây
đây cái tiện xí của tôi là tiện xích
Daily de này để mà cứ mở tab mới thì ồ
cái này bài này hay này đấy tôi thích
nhất về e mà T
ru
xem nhìn trong bài nào r Tít hay Ôi chỉ
không có tâm về
cái p wi đ lắm Bởi vì đôi khi là đọc
chẳng nhều gì nó nhảy sang cái gì
ấy work pen à không nhu cầu work pen nào
lắm nhưng không thể không quan tâm được
Ồ community pck
á là được nhiều người đánh giá cao cứ để
không
không động nữa không quan
tâm i5 này Đấy Uầy kiểu Tôi thường an
ngồi xem đống ngy C một lúc rồi kiểu
ngồi bao nhiêu cái Tab liền cơ đấy Kiểu
kiểu như thế nghĩa là tôi chủ yếu tôi
đọc à tập mấy cái kiểu trang tin tức
công nghệ kiểu như này để cải thiện về
code hai là gần đây là tôi không thực sự
là gọi như này Tôi không biết là nói mới
ông chưa đó là chuẩn là tôi không hướng
đến làm de mãi mãi chắc chắn rồi vì tôi
hướng đến về sau là sẽ đi dậy hoặc là
diễn giả theo kiểu là nghĩa là cái mức
trình độ của mình nó chỉ nó chỉ ở cái
mức gọi là chắc là mức ở hiện tại tức cả
back end code ổn này biết Framework này
biết hướng đối tượng này
đấy Không thực ra không hẳn biết thực
toán đâu nhưng mà gần như là gần như là
là cũng gọi là nhở có xử lý được những
cái bài toán cũng tương đối để mà về tối
ưu này và đôi khi hôm nay tôi copy toàn
copy code vào trong chvt để nó gợi ý ra
kiểu nó để nó kiểu tối hưu lại mấy cái
câu truy vấn các thứ thứ
ờ
À đấy Kiểu như thế
thì thì nghĩa là B en tôi nghĩa là tôi
Tôi cảm thấy là tôi B en ở thời điểm
hiện tại với tôi thế là đủ rồi fen thì
thực ra tôi kiểu thỉnh thoảng mới phải
code fen và fen tôi chỉ dừng ở mức gọi
là biết copy code Nếu là kiểu dùng view
sửa lại với JavaScript thì chỉ cơ bản
thôi à Còn về SQL Tôi cảm thấy tôi khá
tự tin và Tôi thích đi sâu hơn vào với
nó nên tôi đọc khá nhiều hơn về SQL nhng
nên là tôi không thực sự là đọc rất
nhiều sách về về kiểu lập trình chuyên
sâu hơn hay Vân vân vân
Ờ đương nhiên về sau đi dạy thì vẫn nên
là kiểu bổ sung kiến thức nhưng mà cũng
chỉ ở mức vừa đủ vì thực tế là mình
không dạy cao siêu thấy cho sinh viên
Yên ày cao siêu sinh viên sinh Yên
kiểu thành sư nhân mất
Ờ nhưng mà mình vẫn phải kiểu nắm chắc
lý thuyết rồi các thứ thứ cái đấy nó lại
mảng khác đấy còn gì nhở Còn không thì
gần đây tôi vẫn nghe m cái kiểu dạng như
là tôi hôm hôm trước để link ch mấy ông
này đôi khi nghe kiểu Podcast chẳng hạn
đấy đấy Podcast bên spum này đấy
à vân vân và tôi theo dõi nhiều kênh
YouTube để xem các vlogger các reviewer
các
MC để mà họ nói là những cái kênh về chủ
đề mình thích để quan tâm à Để xem cách
họ nói về về sau sa Tôi định làm diễn
giảm mà nói chung là tôi cảm thấy là
mình luôn nên theo dõi
À tất cả mọi người luôn ấy tôi theo dõi
tôi không biết kể mấy hôm trưa tôi theo
dõi cả những cái kênh mà thực sự là họ
gần như là mới lập ấy
nhng kiểu Tôi cứ thấy ông Vlog nào kiểu
đặc biệt các bạn nữ đấy Kiểu rõ ràng mới
lập kênh mới có chục người theo dõi tôi
vẫn theo dõi Bởi vì tôi cảm thấy là họ
phải có một đ động lực rất là to lớn nào
khi mà có thể kiểu Chắc là phải một là
đam mê hay là động lực gì gì đó mới mới
có thể kiểu Mở hẳn kênh kiểu review hay
là kiểu Vlog tầm này vì trên mạng quá
Nhã nhản Rồi Đầy rồi đúng không th họ
cái cái cái chết riêng của họ là gì đấy
mình thể học hỏi tham
khảo học hỏi tham khảo nhá không phải
bắt trước
đâu
nên là tôi nghĩ là tôi thực sự là bây
giờ để mà nói tôi không đọc sách nhiều
nữa cho dù tôi khuyên là mấy ông vẫn nên
đọc sách bởi vì trên đấy mới gọi là đầy
đủ kiểu người ta Người ta viết sách có
lý do cả người ta cố Đặng hết rất nhiều
kiến thức trên đấy đọc mấy cái kiểu như
này đôi khi nó có bị lặp lại này hoặc nó
giật Tít nó chung chung kiểu người ta
viết cho có thôi chứ để thực sự sách thì
tôi cảm thấy tinh hoa hội tụ nhiều hơn
tôi cũng có nhiều quyển sách nhưng mà
tôi thì đúng à ờ nhỉ l lắm không đọc ồn
quá có những quyển kiểu clean code hay
clean coder cò mới mới đọc cái trang đầu
nhưng viết thuần bán bao nhiêu Anh tôi
không biết được khái niệm đầy đủ chức
năng của ông là gì nếu mà nếu mà chỉ đơn
giả là kiểu đăng lên Xong xong rồi xem
được xem được thông tin xong rồi rồi ấn
ấn nút đặt mua xong rồi ông phải vào thủ
công ấn nút thay đổi giống như là kiểu
cái đồ án một Đúng kiểu viết thuần ấy
thì nó không có đáng gì mấy đâu
Ờ Còn nếu mà nói chung là nó lại liên
quan quay lại bài toán việc là ông tìm
được khách hàng kiểu dạng là phù hợp
đúng nhu cầu của họ thì nó sẽ có giá
đúng không v ông nổ giá lên kiểu tầm bởi
vì V nó là vẫn là code thì chắc chắn nó
sẽ nên đắt hơn so với việc ông kéo thải
một WordPress nhưng mà ông mà dot quá
thì thực ra người ta thả dùng WordPress
nó còn nhiều tính năng
hơn data analytic có phải mảng it không
anh nhỉ Có và tôi cũng cân nhắc làm data
analytic vì tôi thích
SQL Anh có thể cho em xin cấu hình docer
của anh không ạ
Ờ tôi cái docker này tôi Thực ra tôi
cũng không biết cấu hình như nào V công
ty kiểu Anh le Anh ấy chia sẻ dùng thôi
nhưng mà chắc tôi không chia sẻ mới ông
được vì cũng chẳng biết là không biết
động cái thông tin nhạy cảm hay không
nhưng mà cái này chắc là ông tôi thì đấy
Có bạn bảo là hình như là tôi tôi dùng
cái inmate của lad thôi cũng chẳng có
cấu hình gì ở g gớm
đâu Anh có làm bod không ạ Ờ công ty cũ
của tôi làm bod còn bây giờ tôi làm Bên
mảng grop ship nó là trang thê mại điện
tử về kiểu Hồi trước là sản phẩm y nấn
Còn bây giờ đi thêm cả về kiểu bán mọi
sản phẩm nó giống dropship nó nghe nge
na ná có một tí na ná giống kiểu shope
ấ anh cho hỏi em Anh cho em hỏi làm sao
để mình có thể cả hiện tốt việc học code
ạ Ừ code nhiều lên và kiểu nên tham khảo
code mọi người cũng như là đấy đăng lên
để mọi người tự review tự đánh giá nhau
th nó sẽ cải hiện dần lên
chuẩn thì như nào bedo
b
à B pp á
Ừ tôi không làm về B kiểu dạng B này lắm
nên tôi không biết được nhận xét như th
nào
thực tập b en nên có là gì thì nó vẫn là
chung chung thôi Nó là quan trọng vẫn là
tư duy và cái xử lý được bài toán hình
dung được là kiểu người dùng kiểu thực
ra tôi dạy cho mấy ông đồ án một à Cái
đồ án Cơ bản đồ án nâng cao code là kiểu
để bạn hình dung được toàn bộ cái bức
tranh là kiểu là một lập trình viên thì
khi phân tích khi phân tích bài toán là
xử lý nó như nào tôi dạy mấy ông không
hoàn toàn về code đâu Tôi dạy mấy ông
gần như là từ trước n vẫn thường kiểu
Chú yếu nó vẫn liên quan đến tư duy đấy
nghĩa là để khi mà mình gặp vấn đề mình
xử lý như
nào thì Đấy đấy là cái cần có của một
lập trình viên
à lập trình viên bình thường không liên
quan cả backen nữa còn n như backen thì
thực ra là họ được không cần phải động
vào giao diện X là cũng quá vui
nào ạ
h bắt đầu cũng bắt đầu nhảy sang mấy câu
hỏi về kiểu dạng của fer rồi Thế mấy câu
hỏi này các bạn hỏi trên mạng có nhiều
mà hỏi chat trả lời được thử copy một
câu sang chatd trả lời nhá chính tôi Tôi
cảm thấy là ờ đây thi cho tí đi bốn chấm
cho máu nhá
react đấy react này view này
hỏi th ra hỏi trên mạng có đầy mà Ông
hỏi tôi cũng chả nề làm gì cả mấy ông
hỏi tôi gần như là tôi cảm thấy đôi khi
mấy ông hỏi giống kiểu Hỏi hỏi gì ạ hỏi
bẫy hơn kểu tôi mà chờ sai mấy ông kểu a
hh chả sai khá trên mạng rồi
nhá thực sự là trên mạng mấy cái này có
hết rồi mà tôi gần như là hồi tôi bắt
đầu đi làm tôi không Ờ hỏi mấy câu h
luôn tôi không quan tâm với việc là p nó
chết chưa và đến bây giờ thì người ta
vẫn bảo tôi pp chết rồi th ra tôi vẫn
chẳng quan tâm kiểu bởi vì ngôn ngữ hay
mọi thứ nó vẫn là nó chỉ là công cụ thôi
mình thích mình nhảy sang B cái gì chẳng
được hồi đầu tôi đi làm tôi biết pp
nhưng mà công ty bảo tôi là nhảy sang
hẳn la ph qu xong rồi à Dùng Angola xong
rồi dùng jig dùng bú chap Hồi đấy tôi
chẳng h biết kiểu công ty Bảo tôi làm gì
Ok thì em nhảy saang Em có thể mất thời
gian đọc tài liệu kiểu các thứ lúc đầu
chật vặt thôi nhưng em quan tâm gì đâu
cộ ty bảo mình làm gì mình làm thấy
nó mấy ông bây giờ kiểu hình như là bị
nhiều lựa chọn quá nên mấy ông bị loạn
ấy không biết được học cái này có thất
nghiệp không học cái này đi làm Lương
thế nào Đừng Mình phải quan tâm vế việc
là mình học được hay không đấy Cái cần
quan tâm nhất rồi ông ông cứ chọn một
cái bất kỳ ông cắm đầu vào Học cắm đầu
vào làm xong rồi ông ông đi làm ông
phỏng đi phỏng vấn ông không phỏng vấn
được thì chứng tỏ là năng lực ông chưa
đủ tư duy ông chưa đủ và và người ta
không nhìn thấy cái sự đam mê sự nỗ lực
của ông cái phần mềm Mấy cái phần mềm
ông làm để trình bày họ quá sơi sải kiểu
như thế thì ông thể hỏi người khác thì
người khác góp ý ông x ông lại cắm đầu
ông làm tiếp Nói chung là đừng có nên đi
giải CV quá nhiều Xong rồi kiểu ghi
phòng vấn liên tục khi mà ông không đọng
lại được thực sự là kiểu mình phải cải
thiện cái gì để mà để mà kiểu nhà tuyển
dụng Cần tự nhiên nhắc cái này tôi lại
nhớ chuyện tình cảm của bản thân nó nó n
ná giống như liên quan đến chuyện tình
cảm và mấy ông mấy ông bây giờ ngồi xem
tôi có khi cũng cứ cho tầm một nửa đi
tầm một nửa đang độc thân chẳng ạn một
nửa là còn ít đấy đấy thì thì Nana giống
như mấy ông bây giờ đang tự thắc mắc K
Tại sao mình ở độc thân mình mình đi nói
chuyện với con gái hay K đi hành hò các
thứ đều bị từ chối vân vân thì cái này
bởi vì mấy ông không cải thiện bản thân
của mình nên là khi mà khi mà gặp người
khác không chứng tỏ được năng lực bản
thân vân vân thì ông cứ có đi H họ chục
hay trăm thì nó cũng sẽ bị từ chối thôi
giống như hệt như việc ông bị từ chối
Phong vấn vậy ông sẽ phải cải thiện bản
thân các thứ các thứ để mà để mà kiểu về
sau công ty kiểu phải săn đuổi ông r nó
dùng tử hơi quá Nhưng mà kiểu dạng công
ty sẽ cảm thấy ông phù hợp giống như các
bạn nữ về sau
thấy kiểu dạng là hồi trước tôi từng kể
mấy ông chưa Không có chuyện là mấy ông
Tán được con gái chủ yếu là các bạn ấy
nhìn thấy ông có phù hợp và có cửa thì
người ta bật đàn xanh cho mấy ông thôi
chứ mấy ông không có chuyện tán được Các
bạn
thấy công ty nó sẽ
hiện tại ít nhất là hẹn hò nhá chưa nói
việc hôn nhân nhá Nó không khác gì việc
ông đi phỏng vấn công ty ông ký hợp đồng
làm ở công ty đấy cả nó là lâu dài cá
thử thứ nó cam kết các thứ như
thế một con hệ đôi bên cùng có
không mấy ông cũng bỏ thời gian à Mấy
ông không đi làm mấy ông được tiền đây
là mấy ông có thể mất tiền nhưng không
không không không nói
cảnh đừng quan tâm với việc là bạn kia
có tận chục anh theo đuổi quan tâm bản
thân mình
phn ống đủ chưa Thế vì thế Bây giờ ông
thứ nhất là ông không chấp nhận ông thất
nghiệp đúng không Cũng giống như ông
không chấp nhận ông độc thân đúng không
Thì ông bây giờ phải làm gì ông đi kiểu
Ờ kiếm Kiếm cái công ty không Có ai
không Có ai kiểu đăng ký vào để ông đỡ
phải cạnh tranh à Nghĩa là kiếm một
người mà kiểu Chắc chắn là không không
ai theo đuổi để mình không phải cạnh
tranh à Chắc chắn là mấy ông chẳng muốn
thế Đúng không mấy ông cũng kiểu cũng
gọi
là cũng muốn bạn kia như nào như nào Đấy
thì mình sẽ phải phấn đấu phải xứng đáng
với bạn đấy thì thế mếu muốn vào công ty
nó cũng gọi là chất lượng ổn một tí để
mà thực sự vào đấy học hỏi được thêm gì
đấy để mà nó phát triển được lâu dài
kiểu cảm thấy là có cơ hội nhiều vân vân
thì rõ ràng ông phải phải phấn đấu để
cạnh tranh
Ờ cũng đúng một phần
Ờ nhưng mà chuẩn như bạn vừa mô tả cái
cái a cái ví dụ của bạn ấy thì nó lại
thiên về cái ui là kiểu trải nghiệm
người dù thực tế là cái đấy là một phần
thôi mình làm backend được mình quan tâm
về việc là sản phẩm đấy Nó kiểu cái cái
xử lý nó nên như th nào thứ nhất là nó
tối ưu này Thứ hai là nó thân thiện
thân thân thiện với người dùng ha kiểu
dễ dùng dễ dùng thân thiện chưa chắc đâ
đã phải là kiểu giao diện phải đẹp rồi
giao diện thân hiện nha mà Nó là kiểu
bấm vào nút này Thực ra nó nó để làm
hành động này còn không nó sẽ bảo lỗi
kiểu như
này cả ngày hôm nay tôi ngồi code là một
cái điện hình cả ngày hôm nay mấy ông
biết là tôi ngồi fix cái đoạn bức nó chỉ
đơn giản là kìa
bác en trả về cái lỗi rất là chung Trung
kìa là update không thành công đấy Kiểu
như thế Ô kiểu người dùng lúc ấy kiểu
chẳng biết phải làm gì cả kiểu
tao tao bấm vàoo cái nút tao tao kiểu
chỉ mong đợi là kiểu nó được cập nhật
đúng không Còn nếu không thì nó phải báo
cái lỗi là kiểu Tại sao nó không được
cập nhật vào lỗi ra trung chung cập nhật
không thành công Đấy còn việc lỗi Tại
sao thì mày đoán xem kiểu thế tôi phải
ngồi sửa lại h cái đoạn đấy để hiển thị
ra ờ cái báo lỗi cụ thể cho khách hàng
ít nhất là như thế đấy là một cái phần
mềm thân thiện phần mềm thân thiện không
phải phần mềm không có bấc làm gì câu
chuyện phần mềm nào không có bấc không
có lỗi không kiểu chạy ngon phần mềm đấy
thì chắc là nhập vào nhập vào chiều cao
rồi in ra đúng cái chiều cao vừa nhập
may ra phần mềm không có bấc
chứ Chứ thực thực tế là kiểu rõ ràng là
mình
mình làm mình phải hiểu được là thực sự
người dùng cần gì nếu mà làm được quá
luôn cái việc người dùng cần thì càng
tốt kiểu là trước khi có Facebook thì
không ai nghĩ là sẽ cần mạng xã hội
nhưng mà khi có rồi thì người ta à thực
ra tao cần này ta nghiện đấy chẳng ăn
thế nhưng mà tôi không nói Nỗi mức vĩ
đại được như thế chỉ nói dừng ở mức độ
là K bây giờ khách hàng dùng cái phần
mềm ông Thực ra là nó sẽ cần những cái
gì và
Và nó có thể không thể nói được cho ông
là thực sự nó cần những cái gì nhưng mà
ông hiểu được là nó cần những cái gì đ
tốt đấy là tư duy khác biệt của Jin và
sho sho sẽ có nhiều kinh nghiệm và sẽ
biết được thực sự mình cần gì hơn đúng
không phần mềm thân thiện là phần mềm
chắc chắn không phải Zalo đây Ui tôi có
thể bình luận ở trên thứ tôi không dám
bình luận nhưng mà nói chung là tôi
Chúng ta không nên nhắc mấy cái nhạy cảm
đây tôi sẽ không nói gì cả
biết đâu về sau tôi Tôi không nói biết
đâu về sau bên đấy mời tôi hay đại diện
gì đâu nhá Tôi nói là không không nên đ
không nhắc gì với mấy ông lớn đặc biệt
liên quan đến Việt Nam chứ tự nhiên về
sau có gì về sau kiểu gì tôi nghĩ về sau
mình muốn nổi mà tự nhiên nó mấy ông xem
được biết được cái video xong rồi mấy
ông kiểu dìm cho thì không nổi lên được
chỉ nổi lên phanh
thôi
toán hoặc các bài tập về SQL đúng không
Đúng kiểu thực ra như tôi vừa nãy tôi có
chia sẻ đó là thực sự là ông muốn ông
ông ông
muốn muốn theo cái mảng nào tập trung
vào mảng nào giống như vừa nãy tôi nói
tôi Thực sự tôi rất muốn tập trung vào
mảng SQL đ tôi thể chuy sâu SQL thật còn
Ông thích kiểu dạng tôi có quen nhiều
ông kiểu ngồi code được Java cả x chẳng
hạn thì ông ấy sẽ thiên hướng về kiểu
thật toán ông thiên hướng về kiểu hướng
đối tượng làm những cái bài toán kiểu
phức tạp các thứ thế tùy mấy ông
thực tập được không ạ
Ừ tôi chỉ biết rồi nhận ra được bài học
đó là
ờ Mọi thứ không hề như mình nghĩ đến đấy
là xác định đừng có hy vọng là có ai đó
hỗ trợ mình Bởi vì người ta không hề có
nghĩa vụ phải hỗ trợ bạn người ta được
trả lương đến đấy và bạn đi tập bạt cũng
gần như là cũng được trả gì gì đó để
ngồi đấy Nên là khả năng tự học các bạn
sẽ phải tốt hơn bình thường chứ không
chuyện là kiểu đến đấy có người cầm tay
chỉ lối đừng có hy vọng điều đấy đừng có
nghĩ rằng là Ok mình ở nhà mình không
biết gì hay mình đi thực tập cho mình
biết đừng phải là ở nhà mình đã biết
được cái gì đó rồi đến tấy mình vận dụng
cái mình biết và để mình học thêm nó
khác nhau đấy rất nhiều người kiểu đi
thực tập xong họ shc xong rồi Thậm chí
họ về họ bỏ ngành rồi đủ thứ bởi vì cảm
thấy là đi thực tập nó khác biệt quá đấy
là chưa nói đi làm đ nhá đấy hoặc là
nhiều hôm đi thực tập xong ngồi chơi Ui
họ quản em chẳng gắt gì cả em đến mang
tiếng đến công ty em thể làm bất kỳ việc
gì Em muốn chơi kiểu thế Thế thì cũng
chịu Thế thì không lớn này được theo tôi
quan điểm như thế đó là mình đi làm thì
mình xác định cái tinh thần là đó là đi
làm thế Mình
à mình không gọi như đi học tôi chẳm từ
ngồi chơi đi làm rồii sẽ không ngồi chơi
nếu mà hết việc không có gì để làm thì
tôi đi về tôi đi nét việc thì phải ngồi
đấy để để ngồi chơi kê nhỉ tâm sự ô nãy
giờ gần bốn mươi mấy phút chỉ ngồi tâm
sự thế Bây giờ tôi sẽ dạy tôi sẽ ngồi
làm tiếp thi nhỉ Không không lại kiểu bị
cuốn quá
tôi nhớ là mới chỉ mới chỉ xong cái hom
page nhưng mà tôi có chỉ mấy ông
qua m đă nhập v
h nhớ là tôi không lưu mật khẩu cái này
ở đâu cả cái này đang nhập m để làm gì
nhỉ thô kệ đi không chậm
nà đây không lỗi
đâu mình có chắc về view đâu Làm sao dạy
trước là đang ngồi hứng lên ngồi sửa lại
cái đoạn
này
là
đang chạy cái kia này load nó Phả chậm
hơn
đấy hôm trước tôi có đề cập Nếu mà giả
sử mà dùng cách kết hợp với dùng kiểu
kch TC Kể như này thì ông mấy ông phải
chuyển qua dùng Credit thì nó mới hỗ trợ
kiểu cách driver mình đang để file nên
thày ra nó sẽ không Hỗ Trợ kch Tác tôi
để redit này không nhớ là thằng thằng
này tôi đã cấu hình cho cho Credit chưa
có vẻ là chưa Ok Thế tạm Xán đi
trước mới làm hình như là hôm trước m
mình mới chỉ làm dừng lại ở chỗ newal
này thôi thì phải tôi xem lại phát không
nhớ lắm
này vãi Ừ chắc là có khi là mình toàn bộ
bộ h page xong rồi đấy Bây giờ mình thử
bấm vào đây cái nhìn thế này không bấm
được mình cười quá bấm Lậy không được
này bấm vào đây không được này Ok coi
như là không bấm được cái gì đi sang bên
tất cả sản phẩm đi Ok hôm nay mình bắt
đầu làm sang bên sản phẩm nhá yeah Cái
này là chắc là dùng sher nên kiểu bị lỗi
hình ảnh ok
Ồ bên sản phẩm
này bấm vào sản phẩm để xem này
đúng
không sản phẩm này không xem được à đình
ấy à đây Hồi trước tôi làm cái vụ này
bấm vào sản phẩm này không bấm được à À
đây Cái này không bấm được cái trên này
bấm được lại ngồi sửa tiếp thôi Ờ đấy
nghĩa đôi khi mà mình sẽ tự trải nghiệm
như một người dùng th Mình thấy có cái
gì không ngổn mình ngồi sửa
thôi
ở bên này là
trang product
này
tương thích với phiên bản của larel bây
giờ bắt hạ version larel Tại sao thế em
tại sao lại hạ version larel
phải nâng cái version của lar Excel lên
chứ l Excel có hỗ trợ version mới nhất
của larel
e2e testing không không biết Cái đấy là
cái gì luôn
nhảy đến đúng không Ơ thẻ a tôi đồ nhỉ
Hình như có gì đó Sai
Ừ tại sao có thời trang nam ở đây
nhỉ cái chữ thời trang nam Ừ hot code
luôn chữ thời trang nam n đây Đỉnh
đấy Tất cả sản phẩm nhưng nó lại là thời
trang
sao Tại sao thế nhở tất cả sản
[Vỗ tay]
không phải viết un test viết cái fure
đây tiếp
theo
à thẻ ơ thẻ a đây mà tôi nhớ có thẻ a
đây à thẻ a nhưng không h này nhảy phá
định
nó rõ ông em tôi không thể thích cái
điều
đấy
chắc này
form cái này hay không nhìn bấm vào chỉ
giá 50 đồng bấm vào thì đây 50 đồng
nhưng mà chọn bất kỳ cái gì giá nó sẽ
tăng lên
ơ cái này đang không tăng lên này Ừ hình
như tôi sửa lại rồi xem bảng
sai cái này cái ảnh đấy Chẳng có gì đặ
sắc đâu
Ờ Bây giờ trước mắt trước mắt thì tôi
muốn quay lại cái
bên bên đăng sản phẩm này đã
ồ cái bây giờ quay lại bên admin này
quản lý sản phẩm Thực ra cái Menu của
bạn này làm thực ra nó không chuẩn cho
lắm Tại sao vì thực ra bạn ấy vẫn đang
làm đ kiểu dạng là Ừ có những cái bảng
gì thì kiểu hiển thị hết ra ở đây nhưng
thực tế là kiểu có rất nhiều cái quan
trọng kiểu admin vào thực ra thường
người ta sẽ quản lý những cái gì người
ta sẽ xem thống kê này người ta xem hóa
đơn này sau người ta sẽ thêm sản phẩm
này hoặc là xem khách hàng gì gì đó ng
ta thực sự là không không không kiểu bấm
vào để xem kiểu dạng như thế này nên đ
đang có ít thì các bạn thể hiển thị hết
ra thứ hai là ng vào ngồi xem quản lý
nhân viên làm gì Cái này đâu phải là cái
quan trọng nhất đúng không ạ Xem quản lý
customer làm gì kh quản lý hóa đơn quản
lý sản phẩm chẳng hạn thế mà mấy cái mấy
cái dưới này là gì mấy cái này là bản
chất trang này của bọn tôi nó vẫn th
hướng là nó là kiểu trang để mà quảng bá
về hình ảnh một cái sản phẩm không bộ
thờ trang gì đó một cái kiểu đấy
Collection là một cái là gì nhỉ
Collection thỉnh hả dùng tiếng Anh nhiều
quá tiếng Việt dịch nó là gì Chết rồi
Ờ bộ Sư tập À đúng rồi đây đây quên mất
có chữ ở đây rồi đấy một bộ Sư tập g gì
đó nh Bản chất là là cái cái đấy nó ít
hơn nên là mình sẽ phải đẩy những cái
nào cần hơn lên trên đúng không
ạ Đấy Tôi nghĩ tôi phải thiết kế lại cái
trang menu
đúng không không nên
đây này tôi thường kiểu Để như này nhìn
nó
trông bị những mắt ấy tôi chắc là tôi
kiểu thích làm kiểu code cho nó trông
clean hơn đợ thì tôi phải sửa lại đoạn
đây à audo Này đây như này này rồi Tiếp
theo là product
này
nhỉ
MD
mdi gợi ý gì đó đi Nào prod à
cái cái về về mấy cái gợi ý này chắc là
để sau đi hay không gợi ý gì
à à đâu tôi mở nhầm cái gì
đi
lửa
sao
sao dòng 29
á Ừ đấy mấy ông thấy này nhức MT không
Chẳng hiểu luôn ấy Thề hướng lên enter
à
này cái này mình order product sau đó
đến là những cái gì giờ hợp lý nhá Ừ đợi
đợ Tí đến cái gì hợp lý
à Không thực ra không phải category đâu
t Hình như là
tôi thiếu đóng một cái gì đó Ở đây màu
chữ khác như này nhỉ đỉnh
h Tự nhiên nhớ cái quả
Kiểu bị bị kiểu màu như
này nhì màu dưới này vã
chưa
admin customer
vậy Uầy có cả FA C quid này luôn ạ định
đến
Collection nhở Ờ tác giả ừ Xẽ
theo tôi thì ra không cần như này chuẩn
chuẩn là vào bên
Collection vào bên Collection s có cái
nút để mà tạo ra một aor hoặc là thậm
chí là tạo autor lúc mà tạo luôn
colletion là được không cần phải có nơi
để quản lý aor theo tôi không cần tôi sẽ
xóa đoạn này
s không
tự nhiên có chỗ không viết s n kiểu cứ
bị lệch lệch ấy
ờ product category
category kiểu mình mình cập nhật
category xong thì nó sẽ hiển thị ra
category đây này sản phẩm này tất cả sản
phẩm này x rồi từng một category ở dưới
nó mới chuẩn ồi đấy chưa làm bụ đ đấy
new tin tức mới này
này nó sẽ có nhiều cái lặt vặt của riêng
bên admin Thực ra thích cái vứt cái
admin chơ t vào trong này được đây tôi
sẽ vứt vào trong này một cái như
ràng trong code nó có thêm s ở trong cái
router nhưng
mà nhưng mà tên lại đấy hứng lên lại
không thên n rất là
đỉnh
ơ mình vừa nhét Nhầm cái À mình nhét
customer vào trong này
trong
này nhìn code kiểu này trông khó chịu
nhỉ
nữa thông cảm Thông cảm Ừ trông này khó
chịu cực
đó nhì trông có phải đỡ đau mắt hơn rồi
hỗ trợ bạn đấy
kệ không sao không quan trọng
Ờ thêm sản phẩm
nội dung các thứ các thứ Ờ tôi nhớ không
lầm là hồi trước là tôi cho Điền cả
product option Nhưng có vẻ ông em kiểu
thấy nó hơi khó hiểu nên gần đây Bỏ đi
rồi cái vụ product option là như nào tôi
cho mấy ông xem cái bảng database mấy
ông hình dung hơn à
Tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ phải sửa lại cái bảng
này
nữa đầu tiên đầu tiên thì tôi có khái
niệm này Nó là kiểu ví dụ là màu sắc
kích thước kiểu như này màu sắc kích
thước đấy để làm gì để mà hiển thị ra
các option đấy cho người dùng Điền Ờ ông
Em ẩn hẳn luôn đi mình ạ Hơi hơi buồn
Hồi đấy ngồi làm kỳ công nà Đấy Vãi
Ờ tiếp theo thì nó sẽ có khái niệm
là product option và product thì không
nói làm gì nhá Có product option như này
tức là sao nghĩa là product ID này
option ID này value cho nó này và giá
cho nó như này tức là tức là chỉ là
là kiểu mặc định thì giá giá điều chỉnh
đây sẽ là không chỉ là kiểu dạng là ví
dụ Ông chọn màu khác thì như không tăng
tiền lên đúng không ạ Đấy Nhưng mà nếu
Giả sử Giả sử tôi Hồi đấy tôi làm theo
cái trường hợp nếu mà giả sử Nhữ đâu
mình làm cá kiểu option ở đây nó sẽ còn
mang theo nghĩa là ví dụ là
à Ví dụ ví dụ nhá
Ờ sản phẩm của tôi có là túi trà đi nó
sẽ có nó sẽ có những option là kiểu 100
g 200 g 300 g chẳng hạn thế ông hình
dung không ạ thì thì giá khởi điểm của G
gói trà đấy Vẫn Luôn Là kiểu dạng là
100.000 nhưng mà cái đấy là dành cho 100
g thôi còn nếu mà 200 g thì sẽ tăng sẽ
tăng lên điều chỉnh là như nào x Ba 300
g thì thì cái cái đấy nó sẽ như nào
nghĩa là nó cái option đấy giá nó sẽ có
thể kh kiểu nó giảm giá hơn ấy so việc
ông để số lượng là 3 chẳng hạn ông hình
Dung
Thì thực tế là cái dự án này Nó là kiểu
do tôi làm cho kiểu một bên nên Thành A
kiểu chủ yếu là cho mấy bạn đấy kiểu
dạng là tự mình chỉnh sửa được Cái trang
chủ giao diện trang chủ thôi chứ còn về
mấy cái tính năng về sau cần bổ sung
thêm hay vân vân thì Bọn tôi sẽ hỗ trợ
cho bạn đấy chứ không cần nhất thiết là
phải quản lý luôn cả thanh menu quản lý
mấy cái k logo hay là VT khát thì nó bị
nhiều quá Thực tế là Bọ tôi vẫn phải hỗ
trợ code cho mấy bạn đấy nhưng mấy ông
vừa hiểu tôi về cái khái niệm kiểu có
giá điều chỉnh đây không Và tiếp theo là
để tôi liệt kê cái vụ đây này
là là tất cả các option này xong rồi
tất cả màu sắc thì có những màu gì kích
thước có những màu gì và khi bấm vàoo
đây ví dụ bấm vàoo đây này thì sẽ lọc
vào tất cả các sản phẩm có màu xám này
thôi chẳng hạn đấy
kch kích thước
là đây như này có phân quyền không á Tức
ra chỉ có bên admin và và người mua thôi
nó phân quyền nó chỉ cơ bản thế Thế là
người mua không có đăng nhập n nên thành
kiểu gần như là chỉ có một quyền
thôi không cần phải làm bài toán phân
quyền phức tạp gì
cả đấy Nên là hồi trước là tôi làm bụ
đấy Hình như là ông hôm đấy nói gì với
ông em n ông Em bỏ cái đoạn này của tôi
đi rồi chắc tôi phải xem lại xem tại sao
hôm đấy mình thảo luận với nhau những
cái gì đị bỏ code này của mình đi ạ
Ừ tôi nhớ hình như cũng có lý do để bỏ
đấy nhưng
mà tôi không nhớ được thôi
Ui đ code kỳ công đây cái đoạn
Ờ đoạn option của tôi đâu rồi option
value rồi C thử thử à Ông em tạo comment
lại à này thử mở lên cho mấy ông xem
lỗi
không hiểu nghiệp vụ lắm em đấy ẩn đi
Nhưng mà nếu mà không hiểu nghiệp vụ lắm
như thế Thực ra cũng là giở Chắc là do
tôi chắc là tôi không làm giỏi giao diện
chứ em đấy mang tiếng là dân lập trình
code với nhau cùng làm dự án với nhau
xong rồi em đấy còn không hiểu nghiệp vụ
thì tôi làm phần mềm mà chứng tỏ là kiểu
người không phải dân công nghệ còn càng
không hiểu hơn đúng không n chắc phải
xem lại đấy tôi có vụ này thấy đề xuất
đỉnh không đấy Màu sắc này Đấy nó sẽ mế
ông biết mấy cái này lấy đâu ra không
Cái này là cho chính những cái sản phẩm
trước nó từng Điền màu sắc là như nào
thì tôi sẽ gợi ý ra như này mỗi t Ừ
không không phải S đâu nhầm đấy phải chỉ
X với xanh thôi đạn này phải sửa lại
những cục đỉnh mà đúng không cái này là
tôi sửa lại cột đoạn này cho nó đề xuất
đỉnh
hơn cái đoạn này nằm ở đâu
nhỉ select 2
à Rồi rồi gán cho từng cái select
cười kệ
đâ đến giờ sử
dụng telescope rồi đó bọn lên lọc
trùng à tôi mới Chỉ sắp xếp theo như này
thôi chưa không bằng luôn giá trị
đỡ tí tôi nhớ có lý do của tôi làm đoạn
này mình code luôn có lý do của
nó tôi làm cái này đầu tiên tôi tạo này
tôi hoàn toàn thể Điền một khác nhá ABC
này Ok này tôi bấm vàoo đây nó vẫn sẽ đề
xuất Kiển như này à Đúng rồi đấy để X
cái thứ thứ này chong mình chọn nhưng mà
tôi cảm thấy là có khi không cần order 3
như này nữa
nữa nhưng mà Nếu giả sử mà tôi điền cái
mới như này nó sẽ không đề xuất cái gì
cả thì nó cũng không hợp lý lắm để tôi
xem
Ừ thứ nhất là cái thằng này aja này đang
bị nhiều quá nó cứ spam liên tục đấy
Chuẩn là mình sẽ phải khái niệm là kch
lại hay cái gì đó Tôi đang tạm tắt kch
bởi vì có thể người dụng đang nhập liên
tục thì mình phải để xuất liên tục ra
chứ mình không nên kch lại nhưng m không
thầ spam n kiểu liên tục liên tục liên
tục nh cứ bấm vào nó lại spam tiếp gọi
api thc ra server mình cũng không thấy
nỗi quá tải nên chắc là chịu được cái vụ
này để về sao cân nhắc sau Nhưng mà ý
tôi là chọn cái này
là chọn cái này xong như này tôi đóng
rồi mẹ ông để ý ở đây này
ờ tôi thôi chọn màu sắc như thế này kiểu
Giả sử tôi điền một cái gì đó như này
đúng không Tôi bấm vàoo đây thì chuẩn là
mấy ông Nghĩa là sẽ chỉ nên đề xuất cái
value của thằng mùa sắc này thôi đúng
không Nhưng đây trong trường hợp mà tôi
đã có sẵn mùa sắc rồi nên tôi mới đề
xuất ra được như
này chứ thực tế là giả sử lúc mới vào
mới đầu vào chưa có mấy cái thằng option
này này thì người dùng Điền ví dụ của
ABC như này
thì thì nó sẽ không lấy được cái đề xuất
đây abc nó sẽ không lấy được cái đề xuất
là 1 cái việc là mình chưa Lưu lại cái
thằng AB abv này Các th thứ để mình qu
theo đây là key đúng không qu theo abv
name như này không được nên là tôi mới
kiểu sắp x order by như
này đây kích thước thì sẽ ưu tiên cái
add lên đấy thôi Tôi nghĩ thế này nó tối
ưu rồi đủ tối ưu rồi Không sao cả mình
sắp xếp nó theo cái nào lên trước là
được mà đ không đoạn này ngồi kỳ công
làm đấy nhưng mà ông em phải không hiểu
chắc là tôi
phải phải viết sao cho nó dễ hiểu hơn
trước à À đấy do để Collection lên trước
thực ra có thể chống collection
Ừ Uầy đã một gi hơn một tiếng rồi
Ừ để xem
nào tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ hỏi chốt lại với
ông em về cái vụ product option này xô
buổi sau tôi sẽ sẽ chỉ tiếp cho mấy ông
vậy còn bây giờ không một tiếng rồi Chắc
là bạn kia vẫn đang hỏi về à kiểu dạng
là đi
a học cảm thể hoang mang đúng không Ờ
bạn có thể hỏi ở trên kênh discord
server discord để cho các bạn mọi người
hỗ trợ bạn nhé hoặc là để cho mình cũng
vào hỗ trợ cũng được nế bạn thắc mắc các
thứ còn bây giờ chắc là buổi hôm nay cứ
tạm nghỉ à Tôi còn đi ăn đã cá shop nhỉ
g shop không có hỏi gì Chắc là để buổi
sau Ngồi trợ tiếp nhá Hôm nay thực ra
cảm thấy
là ồ cảm Chào em Đã đi làm thỉnh thoảng
có người bảo đi làm Chứng tỏ tôi cũng đã
đào tạo lên được một cái gì đó không vô
ích không vô nghĩa lắm
Ờ bổi m tạm dừng tại đây nhá Ờ các bạn
thắc mắc gì thì điền trong form câu hỏi
nhé Tôi thấy các bạn không Điền câu
hỏi lắm Nó nằm ở cái link này này đúng
nhỉ Ơ cái link này điều hướng đến chính
cái link này
ơ tôi mới đỉ ấy thôi chết nhầm
cả đ
Hồi trước tôi nhớ để một cái link form
để điền
cái link
này vòng lặp Chính
cả
đây m ông điền form đây
form câu
hỏi
không
ạ
Ờ th đấy thỉnh thoảng tôi không không để
ý cái coi như là cũng mình mình làm mình
không để ý cũng sờ không không thể luôn
kiểm soát được mọi
mấy ông